l'icône s'en est allé et c'est une
tristesse infinie qui submerge tout un
pays en deuil a commencé par les abords
de l'hôpital Albert Einstein ou Pelé a
rendu son dernier souffle
nous sommes venus vidiron voir lui
rendre un petit hommage Pelé représente
la passion pour le football que nous
avons nous les gens qui sont passionnés
par le football il est notre plus grand
idole
et de la tête il était hyper complet et
physiquement il était très très fort
c'est c'est il restera le meilleur
joueur du monde de tous les temps c'est
un danseur il était beau il s'amusait on
a l'impression qu'il y avait pas danger
on a l'impression qu'il avait gardé
l'envie de jouer qu'il avait lorsqu'il
jouait sur les plages du Brésil gamin et
pauvre tout lui semblait facile Emmanuel
Macron rend hommage appelé avec ce tweet
le jeu le roi l'éternité hommage aussi
du joueur argentin Lionel Messi
même la NASA publie un message avec
cette galaxie aux couleurs du Brésil
je ne vais pas vous mentir je ne savais
pas qui c'était
les morts
Pelé samedi à quelque chose mais je ne
savais pas que c'est un joueur de foot
donc j'ai téléphoné à un ami qui expert
en foot pour savoir qui c'était
apparemment il était extraordinaire une
chose est sûre l'image de son sourire
elle restera pour toujours son numéro 10
aussi qui une fois sur ses épaules
semblait l'élever au rang de super-héros
peu les critiquer par ces détracteurs
car toujours du côté du pouvoir un jour
proche du travailleur Lula un autre
soutien du président d'extrême droite
bolsonaro comme en 2020 avec ce maillot
dédicacé alors que la pandémie ravage le
Brésil
convoité par les politiques mais aussi
par les marques pelées et le premier
ambassadeur du foot business il sert à
désiré une marque de soda ambassadeur du
viagra au Brésil Pelé avait tourné dans
une pub télé en 2002 pour la petite
pilule bleue du laboratoire Pfizer et
oui déjà Pfizer existé il avait déclaré
d'ailleurs Pelé j'ai fait l'expérience
du choc que cette maladie représente et
j'espère que mon engagement contribuera
à encourager les hommes à demander de
l'aide à leur médecin
autant d'activités qui le rendent
millionnaire maison 2003 la presse
révèle que la star possède des contes
shorts dans les paradis fiscaux des
Caraïbes dès lors la relation avec les
Brésiliens se délitent elle n'était pas
footballeur mais créatrice de bonne une
créatrice de génie Vivienne westfoda
elle est décédée à 82 ans comme Pelé on
l'appelait l'impératrice du punk qui a
été depuis plus de 50 ans une des plus
importantes créatrices de mode au
Royaume-Uni connu pour ses tenues vous
le voyez excentrique donc elle disparaît
à Londres à l'âge de 82 ans et avant de
se quitter on apprend la disparition de
la chanteuse américaine Anita painter
l'une des quatre soeurs fondatrices du
groupe de Saul et de RnB pointer sisters
connu principalement pour son succès
mondial amso excited elle avait 74 ans
place Saint-Pierre ce matin comme le
veut la tradition les cloches annoncent
la nouvelle le pape émérite Benoît 16
vient de s'éteindre
toute la journée croyons et non croyants
en visite au Saint Siège salut l'homme
d'église c'était un peu d'une grande
humilité d'une grande tendresse et
surtout il nous a nous les jeunes il
nous a aidés nous aura signé dans la foi
je me sens un peu orpheline
contre son gré dans les jeunesses
hitlées il enseigne pendant 25 ans la
théologie en Allemagne avant de
rejoindre le Vatican en charge de la
doctrine puis élu pape en 2005
sa marque de fabrique le conservatisme
contre le mariage des prêtres contre
l'union homosexuelle il remet même en
cause le rôle du préservatif dans la
lutte contre le sida la distribution de
préservatifs au contraire augmenter le
problème c'est une nouveauté sur un
sujet un peu tabou depuis ce matin le
préservatif est gratuit pour les moins
de 26 ans et nous avons voulu avoir la
vie des premiers concernés la timidité
il y a de la gêne par rapport à l'achat
de préservatif et là aujourd'hui je
pense que ça va être beaucoup plus libre
open comme ça c'est c'est une super idée
on est tombé sur un arbre à saucisse
l'arbre à saucisse ou kigalia africana
tire son nom de son fruit long semblable
à une saucisse consommée par les
éléphants et les hippopotames mais
toxiques pour les hommes tu as vu le
morceau
ça serait pas mal pour cacher la chose
il t'en faut un plus long Emmanuel
Florian ça avance
ance
pardon
alors il est fou celui-là et en même
temps ce qui m'énerve c'est le temps qui
passe parce que évidemment
[ __ ] tu penses autant qu'il reste
tu te dis je suis en retard
oui
le lapin vous voyez le lapin de Alice au
pays des merveilles qui est tout le
temps en retard et ben c'est moi enfin
juste pour le
parce que pour les autres trucs je ne
suis pas un lapin le gingembre
si comme ça vous êtes sûr certains
[Musique]
le décès du youtubeur qui n'aime cayl
son nom ne vous dit peut-être rien mais
vous avez dû voir l'une de ces vidéos
dans les années 2010 le jeune américain
décédé après une opération était devenue
une star du net en se filmant chantant
en playback sur des tubes son humour
avec ému de nombreux artistes qu'il
avait rejoint pour des duos comme 50
Cent Justin Bieber ou encore David
Guetta il n'avait alors que 15 ans